في السعوديه تستعد وزاره الثقافه لاطلاق
موسم رمضان لمده شهر من خلال فعاليات
وانشطه ثقافيه ورياضيه ويتضمن الموسم
فعاليات مستوحاه من الثقافه السعوديه ذات
الارتباط الوثيق بروحانيه شهر رمضان منها
فعاليات باب البلد في جده التاريخيه
وانشطه متنوعه في الرياض تشمل مسابقه حفظ
القران الكريم وركن القهوه السعوديه
ودكاكين الحرفيين وعربات الاطعمه والمقاهي
ودكاكين وبسطات الحلويات رمضانيه بالاضافه
الى جداريات الرسم التفاعليه وغيرها من
الفعاليات
للمزيد ينضم الينا في الاستوديو المتحدث
الرسمي باسم وزاره الثقافه عبد الرحمن
المطوع اهلا بك معنا استاذ عبد الرحمن
يعني فعاليات يبدو انها جميله جدا لهذا
الموسم ربما هي الاول من نوعها حدثنا عنها
اكثر واي المناطق تشمل وكم من فعاليات
سيتم عرض خلال هذا الشهر بالتاكيد في
البدايه الشكر لقناه العربيه على اتاحه
الفرصه للحديث عن موسم رمضان كما اشرتم
احنا في وزاره الثقافه نستعد هذه الايام
لاطلاق موسم رمضان ابتداء من اول ايام
الشهر الكريم امتد الموسم طيله الشهر
ونعمل من خلال الموسم على ابراز الجانب
الثقافي المرتبط بشهر رمضان الكريم
واجوائه الروحانيه يقام العديد من
الفعاليات
والانشطه الثقافيه المتنوعه خلال الموسم
على امتداد شهر رمضان الكريم
موقع الصحيح تقام الفعاليات باكثر من 38
موقع
وكما ذكرت فيه 14 مدينه حول المملكه حجزنا
في وزاره الثقافه على ان يكون هناك تنوع
في الانشطه المقامه وكذلك اماكن عقد تلك
الفعاليات ابرز المدن التي ستقام بها
الفعاليات السيد عبد الرحمن والمناطق كذلك
بالتاكيد طبعا
على سبيل المثال لدينا في مدينه الرياض
عدد من المواقع الرئيسيه لاقامه تلك
الفعاليات لدينا احد المواقع الرئيسيه في
الموقع
الواقع بجانب مركز الملك عبد الله المالي
يقام فيه فعاليه خيمه رمضانيه
الفعاليه تتضمن انشطه عديده ثقافيه يقدم
فيها على سبيل المثال في تلك الخيمه يقدم
وجبات رمضانيه وجبات الافطار والسحور كذلك
يقدم عدد من الانشطه
الشعبيه يتاح فيها ويتواجد فيها عدد من
الاسواق الشعبيه والمعاصره يوجد فيها كذلك
مواقع لممارسي المهن التقليديه والحرفيه
هل من مواقع خاصه بالاطفال ربما ايضا يوجد
كذلك انشطه مخصصه للاطفال ومواقع كذلك
يقدم فيها عدد من سواء الانشطه الترفيهيه
والالعاب المخصصه لتلك الفئه بالاضافه الى
انشطه
لكافه افراد الاسره على سبيل المثال عندنا
فعاليه قرقيعان المعروفه تقام في منتصف
الشهر في عده مواقع على شكل واسع جدا طبعا
حنا نتحدث عن الرياض ولكن ايضا هي تشمل
جده وتشمل 12 مدينه او 11 مدينه اخرى كذلك
من حول المملكه تشمل نفس الفعاليات والهدف
منها تحديدا هو ابراز الثقافه وابراز يعني
العادات والتقاليد اللي نعملها او تتخذ في
السعوديه عاده في شهر رمضان بالتاكيد طبعا
في جده باعتبارها الحرمين الشريفين في
منطقه جده تاريخيه تحديدا يقام العديد من
الانشطه الثقافيه ويضاف لها عدد من
المعارض اقامه المعارض المتخصصه مثل معرض
المصحف الشريف وكذلك لدينا معرض تاريخ جده
ومعرض
المساجد التاريخيه هذه المعارض مصاحبه
لتلك الفعاليات والانشطه الثقافيه وش
هدفكم الاخير من هذا الموسم من هذه
الفعاليات اللي ستقام خلاله طبعا نعمل في
الوزاره على اقامه الموسم من اجل ابراز
الجانب الثقافي المرتبط بالشهر الكريم
وكذلك احياء الموروث الثقافي
المرتبط بشهر رمضان الكريم بالاضافه الى
خلق تجربه ثقافيه مميزه لكافه افراد
المجتمع وجميل استاذ عبد الرحمن ربما
حتكون تجربه تفاعليه للاطفال ترسخ لديهم
يعني هذه الفكره فكره الاحتفاء بحلول شهر
رمضان وفكره العادات والتقاليد التي تتخذ
خلال هذا الشهر الفضيل مجهود تشكرون عليه
سيد عبد الرحمن مطوع شكرا لوجودك معنا في
استديوهاتنا في العربيه بالرياض